Steve Wiseman he is the Duke beat writer
for the Raleigh News & Observer joining
us on the program as we talk about Zion
Williamson as this case moves forward
how big a story is this in in the area
the Durham area Steve yeah it's a big
deal and you know mainly you know the
rivals are really on top of each other
here right Carolina down the road in C
state down the road everybody wants to
see the big one go down so that's a big
deal because Dukes they really never
been hit with anything and cyan was such
a big star and you know since the
one-and-done era came in there's always
talk about you know these players
getting paid things on the side to go to
certain schools and this is one that's
going through the court system which can
lead us to some concrete answers what is
Zion being sued for he actually sued his
agent first he saw his ex agents he saw
the deal with Tina Ford in April of 2019
for marketing representation and then a
month later decided he wanted to go with
CAA a lot much larger firm for contracts
and marketing so she exercised a clause
that said he owed her 100 million
dollars for breaking the contract so he
sued saying that her contract his
contract with her was never it was void
because she wasn't registered as an
agent in North Carolina and shows she
violated North Carolina agent laws she
countersued saying that Zion was never
really an athlete eligible student
athlete because he had taken improper
benefits so he never should have been
declared therefore the law doesn't apply
to him so she has a suit in Florida he
has a suit in federal court in
Greensboro North Carolina and they're
both kind of going through the process
right now does she have evidence of what
Zion Williamson or any of his
representatives his parents took from
these shoe companies no right now it's
just allegations we've asked several
times for you know what kind of evidence
do you have they had not presented
anything publicly or in the court system
so we're still waiting on that they
wanted to pose him and ask him questions
about it and his that his law attorneys
don't want that to happen they're trying
to stop that they're trying to get the
case thrown out before we even come to a
discovery phase so that's
we stand at this point what are his
options well he can settle with her and
I think that's kind of what this is it's
it's leverage on either side I mean she
wants a hundred million dollars he wants
to pay her nothing so somewhere in the
middle they're gonna reach a compromise
probably before this gets any further I
have to believe that's where we're
heading toward but in the meantime
there's a lot of pressure being applied
in both directions any response from
Duke just their regular response that
you know they investigated his finances
his family's finances the assembly did
it when they cleared him to play
initially at Duke in April of 2019 when
when Michael a Vinayak they made his
allegations as part of his extortion
against Nike that Zion was paying the
coach K was involved Duke did another
look at Zions situation not the athletic
department but the school and they said
they found no evidence to support any of
these allegations so that that's where
they are they are steadfast that he's
done nothing wrong they've done nothing
wrong
and that's where they stand at this
point how does this go badly for Zion
and Duke if they don't reach the
agreement and he has to he has to be
deposed and he's under oath and they can
ask they've presented pointed questions
like you know did you take payments that
anybody with your family take payments
along the way was coach K involved with
these payments that kind of stuff which
again they there's no evidence that yet
publicly but those are the questions
they want to ask him and they've even
Gina Ford side Prime sports marketing
attorneys have even made inroads about
opposing coach K and other people are
surrounding SIA and his family and
things like that so whenever you're
under oath and you're being questioned
in a deposition situation who knows what
they could ask and who knows what you'll
have to answer and what could come out
but is that more of a threat to legal
threat to say hey we're thinking about
deposing your family here and Coach K
and if your Xion williamson do you want
to go down that road right that's the
fear and so I think that's where that's
where the pressure is being applied to
try to reach a settlement and I don't
think they do now they claim that
they've done nothing wrong Duke says
nothing's been done
but yet Zions attorneys have not come
out full throat and said we deny all
these allegations that hasn't happened
yeah you know if they're holding that
back as part of the leverage or what but
that hasn't happened so I again I think
that before this comes in deposition I
have to believe they're gonna come to a
settlement because at some point you
know he asked inside this is one of this
make this go away
but if you come to with a settlement is
that sort of the court of public opinion
is gonna be like okay he took something
Duke knew about this what does the NCAA
do if there is a settlement in a
situation like this do they you know
they usually like somebody to do all the
work for them and then they come in but
does how does the NCAA get involved in
this if there's a settlement with Zion
and the former marketing person you know
they're gonna want to go back and take a
look at it they almost have to and just
like with all the other cases that are
going on the surrounded the adidas thing
and the FBI you know you're right they
want people to do most of the work for
them that's why they're I'm sure hoping
this deposition happens so that one way
or another they can put it to bed right
they either either he admits he did
something wrong or under oath and this
he didn't and then you go from there so
yeah that's again I think the
instability we'll have to look at this
again even though they say they already
have when Zion came into school
Duke has shared everything they gathered
in the second investigation with the
n-c-double-a they work in conjunction so
that you know that's where that's where
they stand with that yeah and I still go
back to the audio tape of the Kansas
assistant and he is you know heard
talking about what Zions family or
stepfather once to go to Kansas this
isn't going to Creighton this is going
to Kansas so where are we under the
belief or of the belief that he wants
something or his dad wants them to go to
Kansas but then he doesn't want
something at do I mean I'm just trying
to be logical here I don't want to cast
aspersions as much as I just want to go
okay I might need something he needs
something from Kansas but then he goes
to Duke and he doesn't need anything
does that make sense to you
it's not logical is it in
real-world it doesn't make sense that
that would happen and you know there was
some talk about Clemson and one of their
assistants who lost his job as part of
the investigation the FBI stuff you know
his involvement with the Zion I saying
that you know he you know he made trips
there and things like that so yeah it
doesn't logically make sense and that's
why to me if he goes under oath and and
says what he believes is true that he
didn't do anything wrong
that would be the best outcome for Duke
in the n-c-double-a because if it does
go over the settlement everybody still
gonna wonder like he said what happened
you know what did he really do we had
the situation with Duke eight nine years
ago with Lance Thomas was on the 2010
championship team who got some jewelry
from a guy in a jeweler in Manhattan
during his senior year and then his
lawyer are the the jewelers suit him has
last didn't aim for it he got it free
for a while
they settled it out of court and they
just went away so again that's the case
where everybody always points back to
Lance Thomas what really happened with
that and what did you know what they
didn't know and it was that it never
really came into fruition how much are
the Carolina fans enjoying this it's
great for them it's message board you
know fodder and for the state Carolina
Kentucky anybody who hates Duke this is
what you want to have happen we've seen
a lot of programs go down like this
right or getting in the muck Kansas you
mentioned I mean for years Kansas is one
of the shining shining lights of college
basketball and then now they're they're
down in the muck with everybody else so
yeah whenever somebody is on top there's
plenty of other people that wanna see em
go down Steve good stuff will be
following we appreciate your time thank
you for joining us
that's Steve Weisman the Duke beat
writer for the Raleigh News & Observer